so just to get started you know cam
Taylor
um are coming back in full force this
season and I love that David
um and Rain what was it like
um exploring further aspects of your
character in the show and um do you
think there was a moment that your
character really got to shine in this
season yeah I mean
I love that um I I mean I was really
really excited to be able to
um dive deeper into Taylor and and um
who's who she really is and not just
like the face that she puts on you know
I think Taylor's learning how to be
vulnerable and like it really expressed
her feelings and not you know you know
she's like the type of girl that'll like
date someone she doesn't really care
about but the person she's in love with
she'll never tell like she'll never tell
them so I'm excited to see like
just continue this journey with her and
and like
have her show really like who she is
yeah for sure um yeah it's interesting
similar to Taylor I think uh in the
first season cam is very much like I was
thinking about it he's very much like on
uh their Turf in the first season so I
feel like he can cut I think everybody
goes to this type of thing or like when
you're constantly in somebody else's
life like you're visiting their home and
you're hanging out with their friends
and going to their friends parties
you're like you can kind of it's easier
to like maintain a sort of image that
you you can control that a little bit
better
um so like I think that was really
interesting for cam in the first season
but in this season I think he can be far
more vulnerable he kind of has to be
because like they're kind of coming to
him on his Turf they're returning to
cousins he's been there
um and it's just like uh he you see that
he's kind of a little more nervous and a
little more Awkward than maybe initially
he let on when he was with belly
um so I think uh it's also way more
relatable in that sense too yeah for
sure and Elsie I mean I loved meeting
Skye in this season they're definitely
um a really welcome addition I think to
the group and I love seeing the guys
together and everybody especially
um Skye with their cousin
um their cousins plural
um they sort of have a contentious
relationship at first what was it like
coming into to this group for ulc and
also how did you find
um the soul of this character oh great
great phrasing of the question
um yeah I mean I you know I found myself
in real life almost in like a very
similar situation to Skye because I was
like coming into this group of all these
people who were you know pretty tight
with each other as the kids say
um but you know it I as an actor and and
like with the real people it was just
like you know they worked from the
get-go and in terms of finding the
character too I like I mean Jenny was
really great about giving me a lot of
freedom to build this person who wasn't
really a part of the books and I think
so much of it was taking kind of cues
from Kira too just because Skye and
Julie are like so close to each other so
of course like a lot of Julie is going
to rub off on sky but um yeah you know
and I just didn't want to fall into any
conventions of being like like you know
uh the conventional nerd or like
whatever
um I like this guy I could kind of get
down and party perhaps drink a beer or
two who knows
no I mean this season I really like that
you leaned into that those group
dynamics for all three of you and you
guys with the rest of the cast
um you guys did a lot of crazy stuff you
had a party you went to like the
carnival you had like laser tag and
stuff do you have a particular
um favorite scene or shoot that stands
out for you guys individually uh David
I'll start with you sure I mean the fact
that you were just talking about all the
fun stuff that they do the first thing
that came to mind was the scene where
everybody's racing each other on the
online on the go-kart track I just loved
so much that like they had Camby but
like God with the flag that started the
race I felt like I very much enjoyed
even though I wanted to be raising like
I very much felt like that aligned with
Cam's like being for some reason like
he's totally the dude that's like
I mean I don't know why it's
um so that was probably the most fun
that whole series at the at the
boardwalk and stuff that was the most
fun I had I think yeah and uh I'll see
God I mean same like now I I almost
forgot we even did the go-kart stuff
because that was some of the first stuff
I ever really shot but that was so fun
because it was it was rained right in
the car and I was just in the little
passenger seat like giving my little
quips and stuff
um but like I don't know any a lot like
all the stuff were where it was just
sort of all of us together was always
great because there's so many fun
Dynamics and I think we we got to do so
much stuff that like wasn't necessarily
scripted just like in the background of
other people's scenes and like really
flesh out the world and the characters
and that's that's all you can ask for so
yeah I always think about the golf cart
I'm not the golf yeah the golf cart the
golf course location
um where because we just had so much fun
it was like a night shoot so we ended
around like you know 5 a.m and when we
weren't filming we were like taking golf
carts and like bombing Hills and it was
it was very fun okay okay I mean I love
that I love that you guys a lot of
different answers
um do you okay I'm gonna ask this
question to everybody and I want you
guys to answer as yourself not as your
character but who do you guys think
belly should end up with
do you guys have uh any thoughts I mean
I think it's I think it's I think it's
Conrad I mean I and I think I have to
agree right I don't know it's just like
you really even though he could be so
annoying the yearning the yearnings it's
so intense and what she has with like
Jeremiah there was a scene I don't know
yeah in the first season the uh Laurel
not Jackie but Laurel uh was talking
about how like belly comes to her and
she's asking about like her relationship
with her father and she's talking about
how
um you know some love is like a a cozy
campfire that feels safe and other love
is like burning and passionate but it
could be so passionate sometimes that it
could like burn everything down I feel
like she has the burning one with Conrad
and the safe thing with Jeremiah and for
belly I just feel like I want the
passion I don't know but that's exactly
why I want the campfire because if
you're talking about like longevity in a
relationship like you want to be cozy
and say and like feel like at home with
the person and like they're not just
gonna leave you at any second you know
what I mean like you need to feel secure
in the relationships I think I think
Jeremiah I think Conrad went a little
too much too far for me this season so I
was like okay you went way too far for
me well they're too wishy-washy for me
yeah
and no security
exactly and is there a character that
you guys
um haven't had time to uh share the
screen with that you guys want to have a
scene with in the future
great question for me Steven for sure I
think Skye and Steven is such an unmind
friendship I uh yes
I would say I don't want to say he's
even dude to be honest right I think
Kevin Steven there's like a funny moment
in the second season when like Camp
first like sees everyone at the uh rock
climbing or whatever and um Stephen is
just kind of like oh it's up Kim we're
about to climb this wall now though yeah
yeah yeah yeah everyone's like so I
don't know I think it would be cool to
like see Stephen pick on cam and stuff
in some moments but it's never like a no
I mean I feel like that there are so
many characters I don't really get to
share the screen with that much you know
it's in season two
um you know we have group we have group
scenes which are always really really
fun but like yeah like I don't have any
scenes with Kim come on he's like still
make a mess and I'm like I'm not I'm
like
leave me alone but and I think
I think Jeremiah
didn't do you know we didn't really like
or Conrad I feel like all of them you
know I feel like I could blossom into
like good friendships yeah well I look
forward to seeing that I know that you
guys are doing season three right now I
can't wait to see uh the next season and
I want to thank you guys for speaking
with me uh today and I
um yeah can't wait to for everybody to
see season two great thank you so much
thank you thanks for taking the time